season two of Riverdale yes looking back
on season one when you were first
starting out did you have any idea what
a phenomenon the show was gonna have
become I did I did you know when I first
read the script I before I read it I was
skeptical because I thought well it's
really hard to bring such iconic
characters to life and then I read the
script and it was like a page-turner
you know Roberto and the writing team
did such an amazing job bringing these
classic characters to life giving them
blood giving them you know flesh and
lots and lots of drama and problems
which I thought was really great well my
thing when I first and I saw this to
some of your other co-stars my first
reaction to hearing that this was in
development I was like oh that's
interesting I know it's always a little
yeah it was a little interesting and you
know my first thought was that it was
gonna be this like super teeny bopper
kind of sugary sweet just kind of fluff
this dark gritty you know show that
actually deals with real issues yeah do
you think that's been part of the
success of the show is kind of the
darker yeah I mean I feel like there's a
lot of fans that are just classic Archie
comic fans of all ages right from from
the early stages of Archie and so you
have them just tuning in going what how
are they how are they gonna do this and
then you have a whole new generation
that are being introduced to the comics
I think through just a really good TV
show that's very modern and I think yet
classic you know I know a lot of people
are comparing it to Twin Peaks and I get
it like I see what the comparison is
it's it's seeing that perfect facade and
then seeing the dark secrets that lie
behind that perfect facade how was it
been for you where you to Canada so we
love to hear Vancouver enjoying your
time event absolutely yeah I've been
coming up to Vancouver since mid 90s
doing different films so I sort of feel
like it's always my home away from home
let's talk a little bit about the
relationship between you and Betty
mm-hmm that mother-daughter relationship
I feel like it's pretty realistic what
in season two
can we expect from you - I feel like
season 1 established Alice as trying to
be a very strict strong parent laying
down the rules and making sure that her
her innocent daughter abides by
everything and we saw in season one that
Betty pushed back against almost every
boundary that Alice put down so Alice
has been faced with that obstacle that I
think all parents are at some point how
strict can I be before I actually push
my child away so season two I think you
see a lot more struggle between Alice
and Betty in that they're feeling a lot
more like equals and it becomes a little
bit of to me a lot of times when I'm
doing this scene it feels like it's two
sisters fighting rather than like a
mother and a daughter